a coronavirus patient here in new york
city is waking up this morning
at home for the first time in months
after an amazing recovery 64 year old
larry kelly was admitted to a hospital
in march
when his health rapidly declined after
testing positive at one point in fact
his family was called to the hospital to
say goodbye
but yesterday after more than 120 days
kelly
was finally discharged senior medical
correspondent dr taran narula shows us
how kelly and his family
never gave up
they call him miracle larry a devoted
husband of 42 years to wife dawn
a doting father and grandfather and a
covit 19 survivor
he's finally coming home after 128 days
of fighting the virus
it's overwhelming i love my wife
saved my life she wouldn't let them pull
the plug
stay tuned back in march 64 year old
larry a retired assistant principal
have been feeling sick and run down
that's when he and his daughter jackie
got tested
they were both positive while jackie
recovered quickly
larry spiraled and the family ended up
needing an ambulance
when he got to the hospital the last
text he sent you don before he was
intubated
he said i promise i'll never stop
fighting what did that
mean to you i knew he he's a man of his
word
new york became the u.s epicenter of the
disease
at its peak more than 500 people died a
day due to covet in this city
larry kelly fought and his family prayed
51 days on a ventilator infections
pneumonia
brain hemorrhages his wife was told to
say goodbye
because you just couldn't imagine
someone like him going through this
it's just anyone being so immobilized
and
you know not not conscious and you know
their
like love of life is not being shown
anymore finally
on easter sunday 26 days after entering
the hospital
larry kelly opened his eyes what do you
think about the nickname miracle larry
i'm very blessed and
it was because of all these people and
so many more
[Music]
prayer miracles love all part of the joy
that greeted larry
as he returned to one of his favorite
places in the world
what did it mean to know that so many
people were in your corner praying for
you
cheering you on i was never a true
believer
but i'm really changed now
because i was so overwhelmed by how many
prayers and thoughts
and i know that that had a part of it i
know that that helped
no one can convince me that it didn't
[Music]
and dr taran narula joins us now so
doctor the agonizing question is we've
got larry's remarkable story of recovery
but so many other people do not recover
so what makes that difference
that's the million-dollar question and
we as doctors struggle with that all the
time why someone
lives and why someone doesn't and
clearly there's the medicine the science
the teams of doctors and nurses
but tony there's two other things that
we don't often focus on hope
and support in medical school one of my
first attendings told me never take away
hope from a patient
and this family never took away their
hope for larry and the second is support
especially now during coronavirus when
patients are alone
he had facebook posts that were read to
him every day
voice messages his family brought him
the bar owner that put up that sign that
said i'll never take it down until larry
gets out
and his wife and the love they shared on
their 42nd anniversary tony she walked
to the nursing home dropped off his card
for their anniversary and they read it
together i love that
families often feel they have no role
here they can't help but in fact they
can as you point out thank you tara